à tuer échelle arrêtez de me saoulé
agatha on lancera la pub tout à l'heure
tu nous merci alors mathieu mois et rit
oui alors qu'est ce que tu fais un
cadeau pour moi alors absolument que tu
pensé à vous ce week-end oui à tétouan
ou alors j'ai un cadeau pour voyager de
manière faire un cadeau pour être soit
acheter quelque chose je vous comprends
ya deux manières de faire un cadeau soit
il peut acheter quelque chose tout le
monde peut le faire voilà c'est vulgaire
nana j'ai pas voulu faire ça
soit on peut se déplacer donné de sa
personne ah non mais je préférais de
série moi qui l'ait fait nous tes amis
stars et bien donc je suis allé voir les
autres de tes amis stars way qui t'ont
laissé un message gtechna petite caméra
regarde que j'ai chopé pour toi tu
aimais tunis et par regarde pas qui m'a
regarde les anniversaires
très sincèrement et rend mon argent je
t'aime verts c'est un joyeux
anniversaire à toulouse syrie bon
anniversaire swing je ne t'ai jamais
trouvé aussi belle que ce matin là mon
cyril je te souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire croire en revers lifté
comme ça pour m annoncer des bonnes
choses que des deux cas et je t'aime
très fort bon anniversaire
je voudrais remercier pour tout ce que
tu as fait pour moi et tous souhaité un
très bon anniversaire
et cyril beauté je souhaite un bon
anniversaire au chalut quoi faire
ou séries c'est ton anniversaire
quand tu verras ce documentaire
j'imagine que ça aurait déjà lever le
matin pour te dire combien je t'aime et
je t'aime bien par vous pour ce que j'ai
fait bassiri je souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire n'oublie pas plus vieux que
moi maintenant de saison jamais neige
nous on voit deux adversaires 18 ans est
génial j'aime cette personne même si
c'est le plus grand escroc mira nair
davantage milices et il a produit un
documentaire la semaine dernière alors
qu'il devait s'appeler bonne
anniversaire baba et ils avaient déjà
les trucs en stock et la grande joie
mais ça n'a rien à vous salissez tout
[Rires]